the designs of Goodwin daughter and son
stand out his show in Reykjavik is a mix
of science fiction and Nordic mysticism
because the fashion industry is so young
in Iceland there are fewer conventions
to consider your own son is 28 and one
of a new wave of top international
talents to hail from the north I think
it's inspirational to live here it's
definitely exotic and I think it's an
it's an advantage properly being you
know Icelandic you know and being exotic
Reykjavik the capital of Iceland seems
to be brimming with that inspirational
spirit design March is a festival
showcasing the products of 350 local
designers it attracts some 30,000
visitors the annual festival has been
going since 2009 just months after
Iceland was pushed to the brink of
bankruptcy due to the global financial
crisis hosted by the Iceland Design
Center the event weathered the storm to
become a fixture on the culture calendar
in fact some credit the economic crisis
as having kick-started the country's
creative sector the crisis actually
affected the time seen in a way that
bankers and or people Beth were may be
employed in areas that didn't work so
well after the crisis they changed their
focus and started doing something more
creative that's the spirit that very
much inspired good window to your own
son in 2012 he set up yo a menswear
label he enjoys an international
clientele but his clothes are also
popular at home
I thought that when the crisis hit the
attitude of people just the general
changed today start to think I'll buy
less to pay more I want to buy something
that matters and this is also I mean
it's good for it's a boost for designers
Vic prion starters designs are in big
demand as far away as Japan the trio's
version of a classic fisherman's hat
earned them the National Design Award in
2014 they use local folklore mythology
and nautical themes for inspiration but
their range also includes a poncho
inspired by the Raven and a onesie that
looks like a magical creature we don't
have a long history and design or
something like that but storytelling and
literature is something maybe natural
for us so we thought this was a right
platform to start working working in and
then from the stories we create
something whistles and the designs come
from that their designs are manufactured
at a knitwear factory in Reykjavik made
from one hundred percent Icelandic wool
just a few years ago the domestic
knitwear industry was close to
extinction but it's now undergoing a
revival thanks to young designers the I
said the green is a really important
material and in this climate it's really
important to have you no good clothing
and good material so it's not it's not a
lie to say that without the rule we
would not be here so it's a really
important material for our culture
the Designboom has also given the sleepy
dock area a new lease of life a variety
of designers have set up shop in disused
warehouses this former leather workshop
is now the studio of or teeth in a
jewelry design team that take their cues
from traditional tools and symbols of
maritime life such as the anchor for the
Icelandic people the anchor has a a very
deep meaning and kind of it relates to
our roots of course I mean we we are
basically all related to the ocean
because we're we're Islanders the anchor
symbolizes our heritage we are probably
all of us are related to a fisherman or
fisherwoman or or our grandfathers were
sailors the Icelandic designer of the
year award for 2015 went to Hilda yeoman
who likewise finds inspiration in
folklore and local legend Iceland's rich
cultural heritage is proving to be a
treasure trove of inspiration for the
country's young designers
you